I want to welcome you to the first of
this year's tere lecturers reality
reason and action in and beyond Chinese
medicine our lecture is the great
anthropologist Judith Farquhar max
pulovski professor emeritus at the
University of Chicago where she's also
serving as the faculty director of
Chicago Center in Beijing my name is
Catherine Lofton and I teach here in
religious studies american-sized history
as well the Divinity School and I am
also currently serving as the chair of
the Terri lectureship Committee on
behalf of the committee I want welcome
all of you to this the first lecture and
also just for your own benefit I think
we also want to thank the members the
other members of the Terri electrically
many of which are in the audience as
well as the university's secretary
Kimberly goth Cruz who actually formally
issues the invitation to the lecturer
and Kim's team who has organized
everything that makes this seem so
smooth and easy that is the group in the
office of the secretary who handled the
arrangements including the fabulous
reception that we have afterwards just
follow the crowds it's delicious and
then you can thank the team I want to
say that we owe this evening as so many
things that Gail to the 19th century and
the figures that it produced in
particular here were thanking the
generosity of Dwight Harris and Terry of
Bridgeport Connecticut for a man of his
wealth we actually have surprisingly
little information about him in a
strange little 1895 volume the history
of the town of Plymouth Connecticut
available at Sterling Memorial Library
we learn that he was the youngest child
of Henry Terry that he was born in 1841
that he married Martha Jay Duran in 1862
and then he was a broker and dealer in
investment securities in Bridgeport but
the terms of his 1905 gift to Yale
indicate a more dynamic portrait of a
person as a historian of religion I find
his words very moving to our time as
well as quite indicative of the 19th
century moment that I think produced
them I'm gonna be quoting at length from
the indenture that makes possible
our conversations today so Terry looked
for this is his words building of the
truths of science and philosophy into
the structure of a broadened and
purified religion so a good liberal
Protestant of his very particular day he
confidently expected a continuing
congruence between science and religion
to the end again his own language the
improvement of human conditions and the
advancement of humanity and strength and
excellence of character most
particularly he believed that the study
of again his words the great laws of
nature especially evolution would come
to be seen as the most potent ally that
Christianity has ever had and elevating
mankind literature sociology the history
of civilization as he put its biblical
research as he also put it all of these
would play their part he insisted
however that the lecturers of this
broadened and purified religion were to
be subject to no philosophical or
religious test so it's okay
all of a sudden Judas worried that she
does not have this purified religion
it's fine we're not testing her as he
said again in the magical indenter
magical by yellow standards I'm telling
you all earned seekers after truth are
welcomed even if their views seemed
radical or destructive of existing
beliefs even mr. Terry Terry plays
special emphasis indeed on the complete
freedom of utterance his language and
would welcome expressions of conviction
from sincere thinkers of differing
standpoint even when they run counter to
the generally accepted views of the day
so Terry expected that his lectures
words would have consequential and
possibly controversial power essential
to the Terry gift accordingly is the
widespread dissemination of the lectures
we honor today though the good work of
Yale University Press and publishing the
lectures and the lecturers broadcast
through yells portal on YouTube so the
introductions that the next two lectures
will focus on Judith Barker's
distinguished work and today I just want
to place her very simply in the Terry
lecture
family tree lineages are very dangerous
things in the study of religion we talk
perhaps too extensively about this as I
think in the history of anthropology do
purported descendants of George
Washington mentioned that 255 other
people that are equally six times their
great grandparents might professor far
apart want to be linked to all of the
teri lecturers equally for example there
are two Nobel Prize winners may be nice
to you lead to them or the presidents of
Harvard and Notre Dame maybe she does
maybe she doesn't what about the
physician who demonstrated the use of
chloroform as anesthesia or the
sociologists who coined that terrible
word Proactive maybe you want to be with
them maybe you don't certainly professor
Parker has a precursor Joseph Needham
lecture in 1935 neither would go on to
produce many many volumes that would
come to be called science and
civilization in China but in 1935 that
was decades off when he was a terry
lecture he was just a pioneering
biochemist better than to include her
and the remarkable list of
anthropologists this is a veritable
who's who of the discipline and it is
appropriate to place judith Farquhar on
this list by my count she is the sixth
anthropologist teri lecturer she joins
in this order
Peter Henry buck Margaret Mead Lauren
ELLs Lee Clifford Geertz and most
recently Mary Douglas we look forward to
her words as she begins the 2017 teri
lecturers with the myriad things please
join me in welcoming to the far part to
Yale University
thank you thank you so much Catherine
what a gracious and interesting
introduction and taking up questions of
science and religion knowledge and faith
even truth beauty and the good I stand
on the shoulders of giants of course
including some who have offered tarry
lectures in the past I'm thinking first
of Joseph Needham actually who spoke at
Yale in 1935 as Catherine said as a
biochemist vitalist an almost religious
organicist at a time prior to his later
engagement with China I think also of
John Dewey the year before pragmatist
and educator who's Terry lectures former
companion to William James's even
earlier lectures in Boston the James
lecture is actually not associated with
the a lie presume supplied the quote
above on the charms of philosophy you'll
hear echoes of his work throughout my
talk there are other Terry lectures
whose talks I've been reading lately as
well this interesting and sustained
attention to concepts of science and
religion has led me to a reengagement
with American pragmatism via Dewey and
James but today I wanted to begin by
recalling Joseph Needham as I try to
take an anthropological route through
Chinese medicine into a consideration of
science and what let's say at least
values and meanings instead of religion
Joseph Needham was a contentious thinker
he was ahead of his times as a
biochemist even in his 30s when he was
one of the youngest scholars to deliver
the tarry lectures as a scientist he
examined the fascinating topic of the
morphogenesis of organisms think about
that word morphogenesis I think this
interest prefigured his turn to Chinese
thought even etymologically the idea of
morphogenesis is eerily Asian and as a
historian of science and China which is
the path he took after the outbreak of
the world war in East
he was never more controversial than
when he declared Chinese knowledge
systems of the past to be science
Needham's massive multi-volume science
and civilization and china project began
to see the light of day from Cambridge
University Press in the early 1950s he
was one among a mid 20th century cohort
of marvelous historians and sociologists
of science I think of Robert Merton
George Sartain John Desmond Bernal
George Conde lamb logic flack Gaston
Bachelard and later Thomas Cohn the work
of these men concatenated to relativize
and historicize the truths of science by
showing that rational and objective
knowledge was contingent on the human
work of producing and configuring facts
these historians showed that European
and Western science was not just a
progressive development from error to
truth from darkness to light
but that science had a history in a
variety of ways they showed that the
history of truth
was not just a triumphal march forward
toward ever more perfect representations
of a single physical reality and the
comparative histories these men
undertook pre-modern physics chemistry
astronomy mathematics and so forth in
Europe could be shown to be analogous to
parallel branches of knowledge and
practice in historical East Asia even
though this world region had for so long
been thought of as the home not of fact
and objectivity but of magic and
mysticism indeed in the comparisons
Joseph Needham himself undertook Chinese
sciences sometimes came out looking more
advanced as science than their European
counterparts at the time I met Joseph
Needham and his frequent collaborator
Luc way John whose picture is also here
in the early 1990s when I enjoyed a
brief research stay at the Needham
Research Institute in Cambridge I took
the opportunity to ask professor Liu
about the status of their proposed
volume six on the history of medicine
and biology in China by that time she
and Joseph had demonstrated great
sensitivity to the Chinese sources in a
number of
and time periods and they had developed
an encyclopedic grasp of Chinese
intellectual history they're very
thorough scholarship had shown the
specific virtues and problems of a
number of East Asian scientific fields
very little had appeared from them on
the huge topic of medicine and pharmacy
even even though I knew this area was
near to Luke way John's heart and her
expertise when I asked how long I would
have to wait for the authoritative
English language history of medicine in
China
dr. Liu shook her head maybe it will
never be done she said what was the
problem Chinese medicine she lamented is
untranslatable I could sympathize having
just written my own extended study of
the practice of Chinese medicine in
English and having found all translation
systems somewhat wanting but my problems
were not quite the same as hers dr. liu
and joseph needham were suffering from a
particular malady brought on by their
own historiographical and
epistemological convictions ultimately
they had faith in the universal truth
represented by the modern sciences and
as a result they translated in a way
that relied heavily on modern scientific
terms and translators lingo the source
language was pre-modern Chinese
superstition and the target language was
a refined modern English science now I
hasten to assure you Joseph Needham and
Luke way john produced some of the most
sensitive and respectful readings of
pre-modern chinese thought that we have
in the english language literature vol 2
on the history of scientific thought is
still a major interlocutor for all of us
who try to engage philology metaphysics
aesthetics and the unique cultural
meanings that inhabit the chinese
archive the accounts of Chinese worlds
of knowledge and practice to be found in
science and civilization in China are
nothing if not nuanced brave and
profoundly honest but when you examine
the very categories in which Needham and
his collaborators worked the
classification schemes that structured
their vast assemblage of historical
facts it's clear that there Amos
historians of Chinese science was rather
determinately
Ernest if the Chinese classics were to
yield a history of science it was
ultimately necessary to carve away the
superstitious accretions of Chinese
religion and cosmology and reveal those
kernels of scientific truth 20th century
scientific facts that could be found in
the classics well at the same time
rather drastically reorganizing East
Asian historical systems of thought this
was ultimately a kind of evolutionary
history or progress of knowledge
approach it has been much discussed as
the Needham question and Luke way Jonah
was right to think of the difficulty of
comprehending Chinese medicine as a
translation problem one that especially
afflicted medicine this problem very
much troubled her and probably Joseph -
at the end of their lives and of course
translation is still a problem for me
indeed having spent a fair amount of
time reading the critical literature on
translation and its general traitorous
nasai I am inclined to agree with those
in the many fields the place translation
at the centre of their concerns
it is often pointed out that translation
is impossible yet amazingly it's
happening all the time and at the risk
of over reading luke way john's lament
i've found in my own work with chinese
medicine the translation problems have
deep ideological roots as she seems to
have recognized my differences with the
needham project our ideological at root
i cannot share Joseph's deep commitment
to the general superiority of modern
science and his vision of the evolution
of world knowledge toward better and
better accounts of what john law has
called a one-world world and this is
where we begin to approach the themes of
the terry lectures and the real
beginning of my own talks on reality
reason and action
or things thought an action based on my
career engagement with traditional
Chinese medicine I want to suggest that
medicine all medicine really is a
special case of the relations between
religion whatever that is in science
whatever that is
many have argued the clinical medicine
because it is so practical and
uncontrollably multifactorial cannot be
thought of as a science in itself the
laboratory is relatively remote from the
clinic this we increasingly know as
whole groups that clinicians and
hospital administrators wrangle the
complexities of transporting knowledge
from bench to bedside as they say in the
new biomedical specialty of
translational medicine every clinician
also knows that effective healing
requires more than the mechanical
application of scientific knowledge to
uniform human bodies moreover though
faith in the healer has often been
invoked to explain some of the little
miracles that take place in medical
settings most modern scholars reject the
idea that faith alone could heal the
real illnesses recognized in any
therapeutic system so medicine is not a
religion either Nathan 7 another one of
my inspiring teachers likes to say that
medicine is everywhere more art than a
science more a cultural formation than a
natural science this can be said of all
kinds of medicine including folk
medicines from all over the world when
I've tried this idea out on
well-educated scientifically inclined
users of Western biomedicine and China
they have embraced the idea no doubt
thinking of the many uncertainties in
play and even the most advanced clinical
settings and hoping that their doctors
are not only aware of the latest science
and using the best technology but also
and especially that they are perceptive
imaginative and artful this notion that
medicine is at heart and art albeit one
that draws on both science and faith
invites us to understand world medicine
with methods drawn from aesthetics or
poetics
but I worry that such subtle approaches
might trivialize a seldom beautiful but
nevertheless
deeply serious collective undertaking
that addresses human suffering with the
best tools at hand but let me insist now
that medicine is the field of human
endeavor that most challenges the idea
the religion and science are different
things as I was preparing this first
lecture in August I opened the morning
paper to find an ad for a one-day
university event in which a biologist
from brown is scheduled to deliver a
lecture under the title religion versus
science forever in conflict this
confirmed me in my determination to
demonstrate that science and religion
are not so different it is not professor
Miller's science or religion that I
might like to challenge because after
all I have no idea what he's going to
say but rather that little verses he
puts in between them but I hope to show
you in a variety of ways that
anthropological observation and our
disciplinary orientation to practice
suggests that pragmatically there's no
essential difference between science and
religion any more than a radical
empiricism and find a difference between
thing and thought we're no longer
presented with two looming terms between
rich a relationship must be forged most
of us have a downright religious
commitment to the idea that biomedicine
as it is practiced in our academic
medical centers is scientific and a
parallel conviction that every other
healing modality is somehow religious
biomedical scientist 'ti and primitive
superstition are both taken on faith in
these symbolic commitments we are the
heirs of that long 20th century
philosophical project of secularizing
truth the great work of positivist
epistemology the drew a boundary between
scientific objectivity and the religious
domain of cultural values ultimate
meanings and spiritual life but we do
not need to capitulate to the
compartmentalization it reinforced nor
do we have to wring our hands over that
little versus when it is looked at from
the point of view of any non
euro-american form of systematic
knowledge when it is studied
comparatively as historians and
sociologists began to do long ago
science in practice reveals its
superstitious and magic
character the unproven metaphysical
assumptions that underlie any physics
the philosophical rationalists
insistence on the universality of
certain fundamental categories like
space time matter and spirit just so
wonderfully critiqued by William James
and other radical empiricists these are
not necessary conditions of human
thought and knowledge as such rather
their specific cultural religious
commitments that as Emile Durkheim
demonstrated in the elementary forms of
the religious life over a hundred years
ago are socially constructed because
social formations have varied so much
and because both knowledge and belief
science and religion are constituted in
structured social practice we have
inherited a world that invites us to
invites us to learn from differences in
depth as philosophers we learn from
differences as philosophers and also as
vulnerable bodies and conscientious
actors following the example of William
James in 1907 with these Terry lectures
I seek to recruit you to a learning
process that has long had a curious
fascination for me as I have worked
through traditional Chinese medicine to
open new spaces in translation for
reality reasoning and ethical action
Chinese medicine can show us a world
known and treated by an ancient and
modern mundane and philosophical art by
the end I aim to advocate a Chinese
medical approach to action in general
not only the action of healing I urge
your attention to Chinese medicine not
because it will directly or immediately
improve health though it could but
because this ever-changing body of
knowledge can give us the problematic
thrill of thinking in translation it can
help us to feel the presence of the
vastness William James believes that
opening is valuable in itself so do I so
let me turn to the myriad things I gonna
begin this first lecture with things
that ever renewed problem of both
epistemology and ontology that keeps
renewing itself in modern philosophy and
comparative anthropology Heidegger
famously uses a humble water jug as an
example of a thing gathered in two
salient existence for the philosopher on
whose desk
sits he challenges us to place this most
solid discrete and ordinary object this
usually ignored thing into its specific
history of making serving and being used
other materialist philosophers have made
the classic schoolroom gesture toward
chairs and tables asking pupils to ricci
them as problematic and imagine a world
that is perhaps not so solidly given as
they come and sensibly think Bruno
Latour reminds us that the very word
thing derives from a history of
political assembly in Europe dusting a
gathering objects and things have lately
been star performers and are more
philosophically inclined classrooms as a
fresh turn toward metaphysics an
object-oriented ontology is inspiring
more and more speculation on the nature
of materiality but I think medicine
offers us even more interesting entities
than these classroom examples to both
appreciate and challenge here's a
problematic and important example from
the history of biomedicine
ontological disease the identification
classification and eradication of
ontological diseases especially
infectious disease our hallmark tasks of
modern biomedicine disease in the
nineteenth and twentieth century became
a kind of thing it emerged with the rise
of pathological Anatomy and later
bacteriology as a privileged entity
demanding to be perceived and understood
by physicians
yet his Ludwig Fleck pointed out quite
brilliantly in 1935 even a fairly well
understood disease like syphilis had to
be painstakingly assembled by rather
contentious thought collectives syphilis
was put together in recognizable
diagnosable form as a convergence of
symptoms laboratory test results and
drug responsiveness even today this
disease is not definable through a
reduction to presence or absence of a
single bacterium since many who were
exposed to Treponema pallidum pallidum
actually do not develop a case of the
disease yet no one least of all Fleck
challenges the reality of syphilis if we
put the problem which of its thing
hood and pragmatist terms the entity
syphilis is a very convenient indeed
supremely serviceable thing diagnosed it
can be distinguished from the confusing
discomforts of its human host and
treated using an antibiotic like
penicillin that seeks out the most
vulnerable element in the assemblage
that is syphilis that point of
interruption being the bacterium and
this antibiotic is no respecter of
persons it works whether or not the
sufferer has faith in it or even knows
what sort of a thing it is syphilis is
not just a figment of someone's
imagination rather it is an insistent
interlocutor of human experts and
refined pharmaceuticals in clinical
settings but the very actuality of by
ontological disease in biomedicine has
been a problem for a modernizing and
globalizing traditional Chinese medicine
this so-called traditional Chinese
medicine or TCM is a field that analyzes
physical disorders mostly without the
use of those biomedical technologies
that can visualize lesions or quantify
microbial invaders hidden inside bodies
Chinese medicine acts on disease without
collecting the kinds of objective
information like white cell counts or
PSI levels that is invisible to the
naked eye but obtainable through a
microscopy for example of course these
apparent gaps are problematic caught up
in an obsessive modernist Orientalism
that insists on comparing China to the
West medical system to medical system
TCM can only appear as backwardness and
lack but practitioners of Chinese
medicine are conversant with a huge
literature recording hundreds and
hundreds of years of a notably effective
healing techniques healing experience
and most of them are not willing to see
their knowledge as falling short or
being entirely in error yet they must
practice in a world where syphilis is an
uncontestable thing even though they
have no history of diagnosing and
treating syphilis as a discrete
ontological disease let me step back a
bit and talk about how the challenge of
a biomedical ontology has been received
in China
from at least the 1920s forward there
have been challenges by modernizers to
what came to be thought of as the theory
of Chinese medicine many argued that
only the effect of materia medica of the
field should be retained in a modern
health services system there should be
relying on science and technology taken
from the West materia medica note would
have been imagined as a comfortably
common sense collection of objects each
with certain active properties good
candidates for a relatively simple
addition into the pharmacopoeia of
biomedicine meanwhile the theory all the
putative least superstitious lore
promised on Chinese medicines body
without organs I take this term from
Deleuze and Guattari it's a very strange
term could they all the punitive Lee
superstitious Laura could safely be
scuttled in the interest of building a
truly modern and scientific China they
could finally claim the same ontological
character and the same collection of
common sense objects as the rest of the
scientific 1 world world fortunately for
the profession of Chinese medicine in
China this abolitionist position never
fully succeeded and as we know in the
1950s the People's Republic of China
established the first officially
pluralist national health and medicine
system in the world in 1956
well Saddam declared the traditional
medicine declared traditional medicine
in China to be a great treasure house
and started to delineate a policy of
expansion modernization
institutionalization and regulation of
the field the rapid growth of
traditional medicine institutions in the
1950s and 1960s and then again in the
1980s returned a number of traditional
practitioners to local and national
prominence these leaders formed
curriculum committees wrote textbooks
and reference works collected herbal
prescriptions in case histories in the
millions and taught vast numbers of
young healthcare workers how to think
and heal with a newly systematized TCM
in the context of this medical
revolution what the TCM
in place of the biomechanical in place
of biomechanical things like syphilis
disease in other words lacking
technologies of diagnosis that could
strip illness to its essentials for
instant intervention in the way
penicillin can eradicate Treponema
pallidum paladin without worrying about
all the other causal factors and
conditions determining presence or
absence of syphilis
how does TCM diagnose is there a medical
nosology how does TCM or the doctor give
a name an actionable name to what is
happening in the suffering body these
two biomechanical hallmarks the disease
in the diagnosis were under intensive
discussion when I began my field
research in a college of TCM in southern
China in the early 1980s I've written
elsewhere about this Renaissance moment
for the field in the 80s so I'll not
belabor the debates here instead I'll
explain the terms that came to stand in
for disease and diagnosis as Chinese
medicine developed in a tense
relationship of contrast and resistance
alongside the growth of modern
biomedical knowledge and service
delivery in China diagnosis for example
is nicely translated in Chinese as John
Donne shreya don't want a compound of
examination and a cut or distinction so
a good rendering of diagnosis which
animo animo logically is knowing apart
but mid-century Chinese medical thinkers
could not be satisfied with that term
with all its association with taxonomy
xand nosology zuv ontological diseases
as a description of their own most
crucial clinical practice instead over a
period of a few years of committee work
among a fairly diverse collection of
experts they developed a methodological
commitment to this approach dan john
wonder pattern discernment and therapy
determination i analyzed this logical
and practical formation at length in my
first book and this this though
a very simplified version of the diagram
around which the whole book turned many
of my teachers in China felt that banjo
launcher as a practice of knowing
illness and intervening in it amounted
to the essential or core technical
virtue of their modern field as a style
of thought this formation expressed
their valued expertise and organized
their attentiveness in the clinic
this was also a teachable technique that
encapsulated the virtue virtuoso skill
of the experienced doctor why was the
disease that is known apart by
biomedicine replaced in this formation
with pattern what kind of an entity is a
pattern the Chinese word in use in the
1980s was Jung or jang-ho a 1988
dictionary defines it as you see on the
slide what is composed a jung-ho is what
is composed from a set of interconnected
symptoms and bodily signs including
tongue image pulse image etc and
reflects certain patterns of illness
change theorists including some of those
who compiled this dictionary worked hard
to regulate the relationship both
contrasting and overlapping between
disease and pattern this job was as hard
as finding the proper relationship
between science and religion eventually
during this period of rapid change in
knowledge and policies the two terms
disease Zhi Bing and pattern jang-ho
were disciplined into a cooperative
existence every case record was required
to have a Western medicine diagnosis
disease diagnosis and in clinics of
Chinese medicine doctors concentrated on
supplementing this diagnosis with a
carefully differentiated or discerned
pattern the result was that in TCM
clinics therapy could proceed on the
basis of the pattern not the diagnosis
but let's look more closely at what a
pattern is by way of this dictionary
definition first of all it is composed
though the definition is does not say by
whom but the ingredients of which it is
composed suggest a particular agency
that of the doctor these interconnected
symptoms and bodily signs are all in
images legible to the physician with his
trained perception tongue image pulse
image etc are signs that are read from
the surface of the body and it is an
essential part of this reading process
which is an organic use of the doctors
own senses of vision touch hearing and
so forth to discover that these images
form an interconnected set but the set
is not out there in wild nature as an
ontological disease patterns come to the
clinic one by one expressed in the
individual and idiosyncratic bodies of
patients this approach to pattern
amounts to pattern recognition seeing
the thing in its integrity but
inseparably from its natural habitat of
the particular human body but the key
thing that differentiates the expertly
compose compose Chinese medical pattern
from ontological disease as it is not
other than its inferred interrelated set
of concrete relations that is to say
unlike syphilis or cholera
it is not abstracted from the specific
clinical situation it is not thought to
exist as a thing in the world discrete
and with fixed attributes awaiting our
classification rather like a
constellation in which William James
says somewhere the several stars might
be rather surprised if they were told
about it to find themselves a
representation of a human myth the
illness patterns integrity derives
entirely from what can be perceived from
a human point of view it is composed
again and again in varying ways in the
clinical encounter it's no wonder that
the great treasure house of Chinese
medicines records of Chinese medicine
records thousands of names for jeong-ho
the pattern is a description of a
configuration not a single term for a
discrete thing a pattern is not for all
that nearly imaginary it is still a very
material thing as Chinese theorists have
argued and daily proved in their clinics
one of my old acquaintances in Guangzhou
for example dunked at all a real
luminary in the Chinese field of TCM
worried that the biomedical and
disease was overshadowing the Chinese
notion of pattern though dong wrote an
incredibly useful handbook called TCM
diagnosis using that term John dawn shed
displaying his practical commitment to a
biomechanical notion of knowing apart he
was also known as a pioneer of pattern
discernment and therapy determination
that is spent alone sure it did not
succumb willingly to the hegemony of a
Western medicine object world indeed not
long after I first visited his clinic in
the 1980s he turned to doing research on
the history of Chinese medicine he seems
to have decided that responsible
clinical work could not proceed without
careful attention to a classical past
and it needed to include respectful
recording of a history they revealed
plural if partly Lost Worlds another
great thinker Lu quanzhen whose best
philosophy was written during the
Renaissance of the 1980s insisted on
speaking of the jeong-ho pattern as a
thing at the same time he placed pattern
in strong contrast to the biomechanical
disease that already dominated clinical
case records in the 1980s Lu explicitly
affiliated himself with Maoist
materialism and practice theory but he
was far from being a vulgar otologist of
the thing itself the word he used for
thing for example was thoroughly
relational and emergence an emergent
what do I mean by this the word he chose
is to assume and translated literally it
means the image we face it also means
counterpart target even romantic partner
or fiancee Liu Guang Shan has no trouble
with the idea that an illness pattern a
pattern of disorder can be treated as a
discrete object he has no problem with
the acknowledgment either that this
thing is composed in the practice of
those who are able to recognize it as a
pattern in fact he argues that the
skilled healer must make certain
limiting choices about what to see what
to read what to note down she must set
priorities it would be folly to see
every manifestation of bodily life as
symptomatic much less as part of an
interrelated set so difficult decisions
to be made Lou guangtian writes about
things in a Maoist sloganeering idiom
that has a chip on its shoulder this is
highly entertaining but he's deeply
serious in talking about a radically
different idea of a thing than a
biomechanical diagnostician of
ontological diseases would be dealing
with Lu rights as if the duay shown
might be a scandal an unacceptable
concept to modern bio science and even
to national health policy indeed there
was a joking comment current among
intellectual and clinical leaders of TCM
at the time western medicine they would
say knows all about dead bodies but
Chinese medicine understands the life of
bodies it is as if they had been reading
Foucault and perhaps indirectly they had
note that the word for anatomy in
Chinese Jeff post translates literally
as dissection study or the science based
on opening up and separating the concept
is very closely related to the knowing a
part of diagnosis older Chinese doctors
as discern errs of perceptual patterns
readers of the images that face them in
clinics saw a little use for the kind of
knowledge about bones organs and tissues
then modern biomedicine had developed
from its history of dissection and
pathological Anatomy a heart or liver
that can be cut from its embedding
structures in the body and known as such
as a discrete and Static object is not a
human or medical thing for them
recall the pragmatic understanding of
pattern that I gave you above patterns
are actively composed from the science
of life I'm sorry to bore you with
repeating this but it's pretty
fundamental I think there are the
symptoms of from the signs of life are
the symptoms of disorder they make sense
as moments in a process of living change
theorists like Liu Guang Shen and the
authors of basic theory of TCM textbooks
in the 1980s and after as they
contrasted the Jung or jang-ho pattern
with the ontological disease were
mounting a principled resistance to a
scientific assault on their very
they were skilled knowing subjects who
had learned through much hardship and
drawing on the effective experience of
their forebears and teachers to discern
the patterns of pathology presented by
actual living patients under very real
material conditions they could learn
Anatomy and younger doctors do today but
they wouldn't they couldn't see much use
for it but let's reflect for a moment
more I want to talk about visceral
systems emerged imagery now so let's
start by reflecting on the dis embedded
anatomical organ cut free and held in
the hands of the dissecting pathologist
or the transplant surgeon this heart or
kidney is certainly an objective thing
it has borders attributes a structure as
object that pre-existed its surgical
removal and entry into the bright light
of the operating theatre we're pretty
convinced that each of our bodies
contains these objects along with others
equally discreet and objective and a
driver's license renewal time we feel
that it is our moral duty to promise
these removable things as gifts to needy
strangers but the individual organs are
scarcely known to us through experience
I might feel that I know my heart by way
of that cardiac something I feel in
times of exertion but personally I've
always been a little vague on the
location and activity of my kidneys and
the spleen forget about it given that
most of us live in a kind of carnal flow
working at best with what tool is in
Guattari called the body without organs
how is it that the body's anatomical
organs became so naturalized so common
sensical even so commodified as
self-evident things in today's world
Chinese doctors contemplating biomedical
knowledge ask themselves questions like
this and they incorporate little images
of anatomical organs into some of their
illustrations as with this acupuncture
diagram from a textbook but I have said
that these guys are bored by Anatomy
they tend to think of the anatomical
structure as a mere passive resultant of
a constructive physiological process
that demands to be understood and its
own
firms s process I made this argument in
an article years ago on female
infertility in which I suggested that a
uterus becomes a salient thing for
Chinese medicine only when a fetus is
growing inside it the heart or kidney
held in the hands are stashed in the
styrofoam cooler in the transplant
theater may have a structural identity
but in the eyes of the Chinese doctor
has lost its most important identifying
features its functions in a network of
interacting things that sustain an
ongoing human life nevertheless here's
one of the delightful puzzles that
presents itself to those of us who
translate Chinese medicine but Chinese
medical classics some of them dating
back 2,000 years
speak often of hearts kidneys lungs
spleens and stomachs urinary bladder
skull bladders and intestines large and
small there's no doubt that the medical
sages knew the contents of the body and
it is also clear that they made
reference to a body without or with
organs the listen watery notwithstanding
as a way of specializing the body they
located effects as more or less inward
or more rising than falling for example
but then their modern heirs find the
image of an organ depicted as an object
floating in space not part of a system
of living activity downright laughable
how did they think about those organs
that are named in the classics then
modern Chinese medicine has a heavily
theorized and systematized special field
on this subject
visceral systems imagery or its own
challenged visual I want to conclude
this first lecture then with a
consideration of the object nature of a
visceral system this branch of knowledge
in TCM offers profound resources for
thinking about things the central
question of ontology and it opens to us
perhaps a rather unusual kind of body or
style of embodiment perhaps in the end
we can even imagine a living body with
interpet inter penetrating visceral
systems rather than organs so let me
expand on this idea of a living body
with inter penetrating visceral systems
in knowing practice i initially
characterized
Chinese medicines organ based visceral
systems in this way I won't redo the
whole quote I think you can probably see
it but the key thing here is that
visceral systems are interpenetrating
systems of related functions that have a
definite spatial dimension this is a
notion of the spatial organization of
the human body that is both demanding
and exciting actually I recall
explaining visceral systems to a
colleague in religious studies the
University of North Carolina that would
be a rule Tison with reference to the
way late-afternoon games were played
when I lived at the College of
traditional Chinese medicine in
Guangzhou in the early 1980s in the
limited open space of one large playing
field circled by a running track too
many students in too many faculty tried
everyday to play soccer volleyball and
basketball to jog to lift weights and
perform calisthenics and loudly counting
groups watching all this energetic
activity I couldn't always figure out
which individuals were playing soccer in
which were playing volleyball basketball
players set up jump shots in the same
parts of the field where football
players dribbled toward an ad hoc gold
marked by two bricks
I couldn't keep track of who was playing
at what but I was very impressed that
the players themselves always seemed to
not to know who was on their team and
which of several balls was their object
of interest this image of inter
penetrating but distinct games
organizing themselves around the
movements of minimal primitive that
distinct objects impressed my colleague
rule Tyson mightily a few days and years
later it was the only thing he
remembered about my beloved research
projects I don't want to push a sports
field metaphor too far but keep this
booming and busting athletic field in
mind as you consider this table which
summarizes the domains belonging to each
of the five master visceral systems this
table is oversimplified but it captures
something important about the visceral
systems networks understood as organic
things this is evident as we read
horizontally for each of the five
systems so look at the heart system
the top I hope you can see it the heart
for example rules blood stores Shawn's
spirit unfolds in the vessels manifests
in the face and vents at the tongue not
shown in the table is the fact that the
heart visceral system is also affiliated
to a parallel hollow organ that of the
small intestine system and also the fact
that the heart system functions are
facilitated by flow in the hand lesser
e'en heart meridian to see how the
interpenetrating playing fields metaphor
applies compare the heart system with
the liver system liver rules processes
from dredging and training as well as
dispersion of Chi upward and outward its
stores blood unfolds in the sinews vents
at the eyes and manifests in the nails
it is affiliated to the gallbladder
system and unfolds in the foot reverting
in liver Meridian we saw that diagram
with the acupuncture man a few slides
back while the heart rules the vessels
the liver rules the sinews but these two
reticular networks of vessels and sinews
are intertwined throughout the body and
even intimately dependent on each other
how can they be seen as aspects of two
separate things a heart and a liver
moreover what's the difference in
practice between ruling blood that's
what the heart does and storing blood
that's what the liver does let's address
those questions by reflecting on one key
verb as a translation of Chinese
medicine into English as a translator of
Chinese medicine in English ah I've
always been intrigued and challenged by
the forms of activity the verbs that are
of interest to the clinician what
English verbs can I use that will not
distort these processes which we're not
very cusps accustomed to speaking about
what does it mean physiologically to say
that the heart rules blood or that the
liver rules dredging and draining well
to understand this verb tool or rules
I'm afraid you have to steep yourself
not only in clinical experience but also
in classical ideas about rulership as a
topic on which ancient Chinese
philosophy focused for several hundred
years in the warring States chin and
periods the original medical writing on
visceral systems dates from that classic
era after all and we might suspect that
the proto medical theorists writing in
the classic age we're thinking about the
practice of social power as they wrote
indeed when we notice many have the
liberal use of words involving
governance in their most technical
medical writing it seems clear that they
were composing a body that could serve
as the ontological foundation of an
antique state a polity that was at the
time the violently under construction a
human body envisioned as inter
penetrating networks the channeled
powers throughout a decent resistant was
the proof the rule of any kind at any
scale could not be totalitarian nor
could it extend its reach only over
discreetly bounded territories rule over
territory and people rule over vital
energies both were a matter of condensed
nodes anchoring unbounded networks so
when a Chinese doctor explains to a
student or intern that the heart rules
shunt spirit while the liver rules blood
his evoking a particular theory of power
and responsibility this form of power
has been sustained and elaborated
throughout the history of medicine in
China even though in the domain of
government it has been rather thoroughly
transformed with the rise of the modern
Chinese nation-state dual rule is not
the total domination of a power holder
over his weak and passive victims rather
jewel looks more like ruling through
non-action ruling as an exemplar
anchoring social order as an unmoved
mover or providing a source of virtue in
the social world those of you who study
China will recognize all these formulas
when ruling by non action is refracted
through medicine in the heart system for
example we no longer see a pumping organ
that pushes blood through a fixed
network of vessels the force that makes
blood flow is the Chi energy intrinsic
to blood as it spontaneously circulates
through living bodies it is in other
words the Chi blood relationship that is
made
in fluid moved through the body this is
a very decentered forcefulness that
could not be sustained by a merely
mechanical pump those things that are
ruled in various sites of the body the
spreading network of vessels in the case
of the heart are already active they
don't need to be set in motion perhaps
rather they need to be guided nudged or
controlled in their flow
so in conclusion given the subtleties we
find in the verbs of physiology and
given the dispersed and interpenetrating
character of the five great organ
systems what are the common-sense things
belonging to the body what is the
reality of the entity's diseases or
patterns that without doubt afflict the
body and its systems what are the what
is the reality of the but of the
entities that without doubt afflict the
body and its systems indeed can the body
itself be a commonplace thing in a world
that accommodates many more than one
mode of doing medicine with these
questions we land in a space beyond
cultural difference beyond linguistic
translations and beyond the merely
conceptual medicines of all kinds work
with real stuff the pattern of disorder
that is a thing for Luke Wan Qin and his
whole generation at least of Chinese
medicine doctors the heart lungs spleen
liver and kidneys that together and
inseparably fill the body with activity
the minimal substances that flow in this
body shun spirit blood qi fluids and
Jing essence these are not just cultural
or imaginary things belonging to a world
that has receded from view rather to
quote wi thomas the chicago sociologist
there are things that are real because
they are real in their consequences in
clinics and classrooms throughout the
world yet they cannot be recognized in
the frame of a modernist metaphysics
chinese medicine with its simplest and
most commonly encountered objects they
speaks the plural universe to which the
global pragmatist must exceed in the
next two lectures i'll consider how it's
possible to think and act in a universe
where so many of the objects present
and for the Chinese doctor are ever
under construction under particular
historical conditions but no less real
for all that
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is a historical question the
classical sources read in a certain way
do not focus on autonomous bodies that
much they're very interested in wins
they're very interested in dampness
climatic conditions and they tend to you
know there are no subjects to a great
many predicates in sentences so that
it's the medicine classically you could
make the argument although there's all
kinds of you know contradictory material
in those early sources you could make
the argument that the that medicine was
about a whole environment and that the
human body was not thought about in this
way that is as a kind of a skin bound
autonomous walking around kind of thing
I I think that I I will be getting back
to something related to this in the
third lecture when I talk about taking
the human as the root because luc1 shin
is the source of my thinking on how
Chinese medicine doctors especially
theorists like Luke Wang Qin want to
look at humanism in medicine today after
the 20th century you know after Maoism
after Christianity and so forth and the
he wants to and he knows this classical
literature he knows how ecological it is
in a way he knows how much it does not
individualize the hit the individual
human body
he knows all that but he wants to make
the argument
that we're medical people we have to
take the human as the basis and in fact
that was the collective choice that may
never have been articulated as well as
in Luke Wang Chan's writings but that
was the collective choice in the 50s and
a bit earlier when all the doctors got
together and started saying okay what
have we got here how do we make it
modern how do we make it
institutionalize about how do we teach
it in medical schools etc etc it's it's
certainly not completely eradicated
because there's so much diversity in
modern Chinese medicine people you know
experts of all kinds are busy
reinventing all sorts of things from the
classics and key they read the classics
right and they can and when you read the
classics there's some ideas that you
can't not have that is the classics are
extremely powerful and telling you what
might be far right and that and that in
itself is is really important it means
that it's impossible for Chinese
medicine to be completely modernist they
can't is reimagine itself as a modernist
kind of empiricism or something like
that because those ancient sources need
to be accepted and they need to be
understood in and and thought about
we on here yes
I'm bill summers and I have a question
about your emphasis on the image which i
think is really interesting yes I as a
Western trained physician when I examine
a chest I listen and I thump and so on
and I have images that I form in my mind
historically I suspect Linette lenok did
not look at think of x-rays and his
images but I think of what would the
x-ray look like or what would the
consolidation be or what would the the
specimen look like if I was in the
autopsy room what did the Chinese
physician have in mind when you talked
about the image from the tongue or the
image from the triple burner or whatever
yeah lecture 2 in lecture 3 I take this
back up but I'm but I'm really glad you
noticed that image thing because it's
really important I one thing I'm not
doing in these lectures is going back to
cosmogony which is an ancient you know
system of explaining how the ten
thousand things the myriad things came
into existence and if you if you take
cosmogony seriously as the kind of
metaphysical foundation of Chinese
medical thinking then you the ten
thousand things are images there are
images they come out and face us they
come out from an invisible generative
process of nature or the way okay and so
the doctors job as an expert this is not
everybody's job this is the doctors job
is to infer to closer to sources to work
his way closer to the sources the
dynamic sources of the things right and
in the logic of his diagnosis so and
that's quite like what a lot of
clinicians do right and then so that's
one reason I think that and it's a point
I made in the first book and we'll be
making again here is that any medicine
needs to read surfaces but there's a
kind of ideological commitment in
biomedicine to getting past the
superficial surfaces and finding that in
inward lesion or that inward what the
the anatomical anomaly that might be
causing
the or the microbe right there might be
causing these images to appear Chinese
medicine doesn't have that option but
they infer they infer like crazy they're
trying back to get back to the dynamic
sources which they think of as being
internal to the body in a modernist
version but they and their their whole
archive their holes training teaches
them how to infer correctly does that
make sense
okay well stay tuned yes thank you my
question is what role if any does food
and diet play in clinical practice of
Chinese medicine Chinese doctors today
don't give a lot of advice about food
although there is a specialty
nutritional medicine and certainly there
anybody seeing in TCM there is a TCM
specialty nutritional medicine and there
are increasingly because of the global
anxiety about food and diet there are
clinics specialized clinics that you can
go to but TCM has been very good at
working on digestive disorders and so
that they have tended to presume doctors
modern doctors anyway but once I know
tend to presume that they know what
people eat and they know when things are
going wrong with the digestion right and
they have medicines which are on a
continuum with food actually this
constantly inserted this is a yellow
shirt on you and the medicine and food
are of the same source right so they and
they have medicines that can interfere
with digestive disorders and reorder
digestion so they are thinking more like
modern non ecological clinicians about
it these days but I think that there was
not that much about apart from the
medicinal foods about which there's a
huge literature it wasn't a whole lot
about pathological eating right and
in the archive in the classic sources
reason I'm asking this is that in in
Ayurveda and what is called Unani
medicine South Asia patient rarely
leaves the healers office without being
told well this is increasingly the case
in China but it's a it's a different
history in India I think hi thank you
I'm James Van Pelt from the Divinity
School mm-hmm
55 years ago the teri lecturer was
Michael Polanyi
yeah and his topic was tacit knowing and
which was is knowing that cannot be
expressed articulated by language and
one of his primary examples was x-rays
that to learn to read an x-ray you can't
be taught you have to just do it and do
it and do it and finally it dawns on you
and I thought about that in relation to
the way that Chinese medicine includes
diagnosing by odor and there's a famous
case of a fellow who visits Western
heart clinic and diagnoses from the
urine of the patient so I'm just
wondering to what extent does tacit
knowing in that sense play into Chinese
medicine and having to learn by doing as
opposed to being taught well as I recall
polanyi's argument
tacit knowing plays into everything and
so one can't say that there is a culture
which has not benefited from all kinds
of systems of tacit knowing but I've got
a parallel example for you which is wait
a second now I'm forgetting what my
Carlo
example is Oh sug adhesive Koriyama who
has written a wonderful book about
Chinese and Greek medicine has a little
obscure article about Anatomy being
introduced Dutch Anatomy being
introduced to Japan and now we have
always presumed or at least the
classical historiography of Medicine has
presumed that when dissectors started
anatomist started opening bodies and
seeing what was there that they
understood the body an entirely new way
it was simple active vision right to
open the bodies and look right
however Koriyama looked at the slow rise
of anatomical dissection in Japan after
books the handbooks and guides to
Anatomy from dissection had arrived from
the Netherlands and he said it took a
hundred years for the Japanese anatomist
to decide that those books represented
something real and that they could
accept that representation as a
representation of what's really inside
bodies they needed to train themselves
to read the representation toward the
body and to then read the body in the
way that an anatomist would I think
that's a fascinating case in which you
might want to think about all the tacit
knowledge of knowing bodies that had to
be recast some of it vanished some of it
refined you know in order for Anatomy to
make sense to Japanese scientists thank
you my name is Dale Martin I'm
affiliated with the Religious Studies
department and Judy I'm so glad that you
brought up sug adhesive Koriyama because
that gives me permission to ask what I
thought might be an inappropriate
question but I guess it's a Judy have
got to know each other when I was
teaching at Duke and she was at UNC
Chapel Hill I was working on ancient
Greek medicine and she was working on
classical Chinese medicine and we found
we had so much in common because of that
and that's 25 years ago or so and I
wanted to ask you both for information
and for your opinion because I haven't
read ger Lloyd or Kuriyama since then
basically our to ask if you could
comment on these similarities that the
comparison of Chinese medicine in
classical Greek medicine have these been
successful comparisons what do you think
of them and has there been much progress
made in the last 25 years in that
actually I'm it's been quite a while
since I've looked at the work of ger
Lloyd and Nathan 7 which is an extended
dialogue that the two of them sustained
about comparing and contrasting Greek
medicine Greek science and Chinese
science of the same period what they
focused on as I recall from that book is
especially the sort of social
arrangements by which knowledge was
chaired and developed and they argued
that with the disputatious climate of
the Agora
in Hellenistic traditions that I'm gonna
be messing this up I'm a little
self-conscious about this that that
there was all kinds of skepticism
developed about the things of the body
and about diseases and and so forth and
they the philosophers the scientists the
Aristotelian didn't help that much with
medicine it took as you know perfectly
well it took Galen and the Arabs to
sustain a working medicine with a rather
different philosophical foundation even
so we'll have to talk about this but I
think that the the galenic tradition was
still committed to a different kind of
materiality than the
Chinese classical tradition which was a
materiality of practice and process
that's that would be my argument and
there are a lot of people who are making
this comparison but apart from Lloyd and
seven I don't think they're being subtle
enough about the ontological questions
about the nature of the things the
materiality at issue that's one reason I
spend so much time on things thank you
for a fascinating introduction I'm Jean
Thompson black and it's a fascinating
introduction for me because I don't have
a lot of background in this area so my
question is in that slide where you had
the organ systems where did the
reproductive organs situate reveal brain
the brain is pretty trivial - okay but
but along with that are there
reflections on gender and you know
differences in gender and the practice
of Chinese medicine very little in the
classical tradition because women and
men aren't thought to be that different
and you know the the surface genitals
for example are of no interest at all
what's interesting is the kinds of
processes that are underlying them and
making them do what they do there is a
little organ visit which I would have
had to have made that table much more
complex - included in parallel with
other things called the gate of life
which is supposed to be located between
the kidneys and the gate of life is in
charge both of reproduction desire will
and all kinds of of fluid control
systems and kidney system function so
the kidney system which was up there has
a certain relationship to the gate of
life now there was there was gynecology
and obstetrics it mostly wasn't in the
classical works
in fact I'll just tell you a little
story if I have a minute some years ago
I was watching a TV serial they have
these wonderful wonderful historical
soap operas on TV in China I was in
China I was watching this TV serial
about the guy who had been the compiler
of the psychotron show the for the all
knowledge and for books
massive project in the early 18th
century which was supposed to have all
knowledge in all the books and you can
that you can find us at KU 22 in the
Yale library and it will take up part of
a room so I was this is this that this
wonderful story about the life of the
editor of the psychotron show and the
this editor was the the foster parent of
a concubine of the Emperor who was she
was an illegal concubine so she had to
live in the editor's house not in the
palace alright she's pregnant by the
Emperor time comes for her to deliver
and there's nobody in the house but a
bunch of sixteen-year-old girls and this
these male editors right so she's going
into labor and they're running around
like chickens with their heads cut off
this is on TV I'm watching this at home
on my couch and they're saying well
let's find the obstetrics in this echo
chuan Shu
you know we've gotta be here somewhere
and I'm yelling at the TV no it's not
it's not there it's not there but there
are some in fact a graduate of Yale in a
wool is working on has a wonderful book
on women's medicine in the history in
the history of China and Charlotte Firth
has also published on women's medicine
in history of China but they had to go
to some sort of off Canon sources to
find that material thank you please join
me in thanking to the Farquar such a
great first time
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]